No matter which method you
use to find your classes
you'll end up on a screen like this.
Let's talk a little bit about
what this information on
this screen actually means.
Under the Select column you'll see
a check mark if you can register for
that class or a letter if you can't.
If you can't,
it might be because the class is full or
might be because your
registration window isn't open.
Next is the CRN column.
We'll talk about this in a bit.
The next nine columns are just
information about the class.
This won't generally change
from class to class, so
don't worry too much about this.
The next three columns stands for
capacity, active and remaining.
Capacity is how many
people can take the class.
Active is how many students
are currently in the class.
And remaining is
the number of slots left.
When a class fills up then students
start joining the waitlist,
which also has capacity,
active, and remaining columns.
So now let's talk about
actually adding a class.